president Trump pitches his record
Democrats pitch president Trump's racism
and the media pushed themselves as
election day finally arrives it's year
it's come the great battle of our time
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
so if it sounds like I'm being flippant
about the selection is because I'm being
a little flippant about this election
it's not because I don't think it's
important I actually think it's very
important but every time there's an
election we are told that it is the most
important election of our lifetime that
by tomorrow everyone will be dead their
corpses will be strewn across the wasted
landscape of the United States I'm not
so into that I'm gonna explain what the
elect remains what the election doesn't
in just one second first let's talk
about the rhetoric that you read in the
news so when you look at the news and
you look at what the news has to say
about Brent Cavanaugh's confirmation
it's pretty obvious that the media are
trying to solidify the left for today's
midterms which means that it's gonna be
a battle for the house I mean a real
battle here's what's at stake if the
Democrats take it a lot of positive
policies the Republicans have enacted
over the past couple of years all the
stuff that doesn't help the economy tax
cuts judicial appointments withdrawal
from the Iran deal all that stuff could
be stymied if Democrats take control of
either house which looks like a serious
possibility when they start to obstruct
what effect could that have on the
dollar on stocks and other unknowns that
might impact your savings
what is your plan can you afford another
hits your retirement like the last
downturn when the S&P dropped 50%
everyone savings plan should be at least
a little bit diversified mine is and
yours should be too the company I trust
with precious metal purchases Birch gold
group right now thanks to a little-known
IRS tax law you can even move your IRA
or eligible 401k into an IRA backed by
physical gold and silver which is
perfect for folks who want to protect
that hard-earned retirement from any
future geopolitical uncertainty look
back historically and when the bottom
falls out of everything else gold does
tend to safeguard savings Birch gold
group has thousands of satisfied
customers countless five-star reviews an
A+ rating with the Better Business
Bureau right now contacts my friends
over at Birch gold to request a free
information kit on physical precious
metals it's a comprehensive 16 page kit
showing how gold and silver can protect
your savings how you can move that IRA
or 401k into precious metals if that's
something you want to do to get your no
cost no obligation kit go to
birchgold.com slash pen again that's
birchgold.com slash Ben go check it out
right now birchgold.com slash pen so
here we are
Election Day now a couple of quick notes
about Election Day today you're gonna
hear a bunch of celebrities tell you you
must vote you're gonna hear a bunch of
media people talking about the wonders
of American voting and it's true it's an
incredible thing that we get to decide
the future of our politics in this
country
it's also a day when we remember that
the people that we wouldn't trust to
pick up our mail are gonna decide how
our families live so that's kind of
depressing and it's a reminder that you
know what's the best way to run a
democracy do not give the government
power in the first place I'm talking to
you Democrats I'm talking to you
Republicans I'm talking to everyone if
the government were less powerful if the
government were not all that important
in your life then you would not care all
that much about the outcome of the
election you'd have a stake in voting
but it wouldn't feel like a life or
death thing for a lot of folks today I
mean when the election results start
flowing in tonight people are going to
lose their minds people are just going
to lose it because whichever way it goes
people are gonna think it's the end of
the world if the Democrats sweep
Republicans are going to feel as though
they're under the gun again just like
during the Obama years and if the
Republicans sweep Democrats are going to
feel like the democracy is at and then
in reality is their democracy and then
no it's not and if gridlock ensues
because Democrats win the house that
would be bad for a variety of reasons
which is why you should go out and vote
Republican today in my opinion but but
that said the alarmism that it's the end
of the world no one will survive we've
got Andre the Giant's out there and his
Holocaust cloak screaming there will be
no survivors like that stuff it's just
it's not the case it's not the case hey
politics matter but you know what
matters more pretty much everything else
in your life really politics doesn't
matter I spend my life doing it but
again I think it's imperative to
recognize that politics only matters
insofar as people are trying to control
your life from above so we should all be
fighting for the same thing which is for
people to leave us alone but that said
we are now into the final pitch the
final day is here it has arrived let
them fight so the the final pitch from
President Trump is basically yeah it
would probably be better if I talked
about the economy sure it would be
better if I were more uniting but let's
be real about this Democrats aren't
interested in uniting so I'm gonna troll
the living hell out of them that was
basically Trump's closing message
yesterday he has talked about the
economy yeah then the fact is that when
people say Trump doesn't talk about the
economy he should be pitching the
economy he has talked about the economy
pretty incessantly but if you're the
President of the United States and you
say two things one is the economy is
great and the other is stormy Daniels is
a horse face
one of those things is probably going to
get more attention than the other thing
just as a as a matter of fact now here
is here is how Republicans could have
run in this election and this is not me
saying that Republicans are gonna do
badly maybe they surprised everybody and
do great tonight the polls right now are
showing that the poll average at least
from 538 has Democrats up about nine in
the generic ballot the Real Clear
Politics poll average has Democrats up
about eight in the generic ballot I
think that Republicans are gonna
slightly better than that because in
every midterm election since 2002 the
Real Clear Politics poll average has
over pulled Democrats this is true in
2006 when it said that Democrats were
going to have about a ten-point
advantage they finished with a
seven-point advantage it was true in
2010 when they said that Republicans
were gonna have about a five-point
advantage to turn into a seven-point
advantage it happened again in 2014 when
they said Republicans had about a three
point advantage and it was a seven point
advantage so it is possible but the
polls are systemically under counting
Republicans again that is a possibility
but with all of that said if you had to
put betting money on tonight's election
you would suggest that Democrats take
the house fairly easily if you look at
the 538 analysis this is Nate Silver's
group the 5:30 analysis and I think data
are appropriate to analyze the analysis
suggest that in the sort of 80
percentile range of certainty is the
Democrats win somewhere between 21 and
57 seats which is a very broad range but
remember Democrats only need to win 23
to take the house that means that it's
very unlikely the Republicans keep the
house at this point if I had to put
money on it I would be saying 35 seats
and above for Democrats in the House
Republicans pick up maybe one maybe two
seats in the Senate because three weeks
ago I think the math was a little bit
different but the narrative over the
past three weeks has not been good for
Republicans and again president Trump's
final pitch is a pretty polarizing one
which may get more Republicans out to
the polls but will also bring more
Democrats out to the polls here's what
the election could have been so rush
limbaugh did a rally for president Trump
in Cape Girardeau Missouri which is
Russia's home town and I've never seen
Russian do anything like this before
which is it's pretty amazing showing by
rush right rush doesn't tend to do this
sort of thing Sean Hannity also showed
up to cover the event but then he ended
up on stage pumping president Trump
which again a lot of folks are very
upset at Sean Hannity for doing this
here's my feeling
who cares really this is my feeling
because was anyone unaware that Sean is
a big president Trump fan hey so what it
seems not inappropriate to me if I saw
Al Sharpton campaigning for Barack Obama
he's a host on MSNBC if I saw Chris
Hayes campaigning for Elizabeth Warren I
wouldn't be shocked if I saw frankly if
I saw Anderson Cooper campaigning for
for Hillary Clinton that would not have
shocked me in any way because we all
know where everybody stands in partisan
fashion in any case brush points out
that President he's at Trump's rally and
he says listen the the fact is that
Democrats talk about us being divisive
they're the ones who are divisive they
never accepted the fact that they lost
and of course Russia is correct about
this the president and all of us have
been labeled by some Democrats in the
media divisive
[Music]
divisive the Democrats haven't even
accepted they lost the election in 2016
okay and of course Russia is correct
about this when it comes to divisive 'no
stomach rats had a patent on this before
President Trump President Trump is
divisive and this is the point that I'm
gonna make here is that regardless of
how the election goes the best election
strategy would have been to run on
success here's President from trying to
do that a little bit yesterday he said
that with the economy that's good we
should be able to have some electoral
success here well it's almost not
understandable we have the best economic
numbers ever to come out you know we
have probably the best economy that any
president ever had when he ran for
office we have the best economy that
there has ever been let alone for an
election so I think we're gonna have
tremendous success tomorrow I think it's
gonna be great hey that would be a solid
pitch who would also be a solid pitch to
talk about how Republicans have improved
other aspects of American life there's a
good piece in the New York Post today by
Mary Vaught talking about Republicans
impact on health care now her husband
Russ is deputy director of the Office of
Management and Budget but she's also the
mother of a child with a
life-threatening genetic disease so she
has a stake obviously in the health
system as all of us do
she says the administration has made
expanded access to prescription drugs a
top priority in the fiscal year that
ended on September 30th the FDA okayed
971 generic drugs which is a record
breaking the old Mark of 937 approvals
set just last year compare that to the
651 greenlit in 2016 under Obama and 492
of the year before that under Barack
Obama the more rapid approval of generic
drugs has an impact on patient wallets
which of course is true also the
administration has expanded access to
more coverage options including
short-term plans individuals who can't
afford Obama care actually now have more
alternatives with more reasonable rates
so they're there a lot of victories that
the Trump gets to account for in his
first two years but that is not what
we're talking about instead what we are
talking about is the troller II and
that's because this has been sort of an
endemic problem to being conservative in
the Trump era which is that troller II
is really enjoyable I'm trolling the
other side and watching them explode is
really in trouble and listen there's a
whole line of memes that are dedicated
to me destroying the left
right there there's a whole line of
videos I mean it's throwing a lot now I
think that those videos are useful
insofar as they are generally done in
the context of a civil discussion but
the right has fallen in love with the
idea of owning the left and driving them
batty and they're not wrong that when
the left looks baddie they do worse in
electoral terms but when Republicans do
the wrong thing in order to drive the
left batty that is not helpful either
president Trump could have walked that
line he has not really walked that line
so here's President Trump doing what
President Trump does best which is
speaking from the hip he says listen I'd
love to unite but no the fact is I
shouldn't say this because I want to
unite I do eventually want to unite but
the fact is we're driving them crazy
we're driving them crazy they don't know
what to do they're going loco loco yeah
so there's that uniting language that we
all hear back now again in a second I'm
gonna get you the Democrats and the
great lie that the Democrats are pushing
forward which is the day are the uniting
party the thing about Trump and the
reason people like Trump is because
Trump does strip away a lot of the
pretense from politics Trump says all of
it like Barack Obama needs to stand up
and go I'm are you lighter
I loved unites people also everyone who
disagrees with me is a jerk but all
jerks divorced and that was Obama shtick
Trump gets up there he's like listen I
love to unite people but I don't care
it's hilarious and it's like okay fair
all right but is it a great electoral
strategy you know here's the thing when
you drive people crazy they do tend to
vote more often when you make people
angry they do tend to vote more often
saying when people don't vote angry
people tend to vote more often but this
of course is also what gets Trump space
out there so tonight we're going to find
out whether Trump actually has a
movement or whether the 2016 election
was a moment in time and I don't mean
that Trump has to win overwhelming
victories in order for us to say that he
has movement and what I mean by movement
is something above and beyond sort of
normal Republican voting now the theory
in 2016 was that Trump had put together
this brand new coalition that was
dominant in American politics reshift in
the censer rejiggering all of our
assumptions about politics and there was
a data point and the data point was the
2016 election but a data point is not a
fact pattern and so the question tonight
is going to be whether that data point
starts
look like a fat pattern so in a second I
want to talk about what would make it
look like a fact pattern and we'll talk
about other stuff that president Trump's
had to double down on this particular
attitudinal movement in one saying first
let's talk about the air quality in your
home so you're walking around your house
and you're hacking up along it you don't
know why well one of the reasons because
you were too lazy to check your air
filters I know you don't want to sit
you're talking about your air filters
it's election day but here's the reality
if you're not thinking about your air
filters you are making yourself less
healthy high pollution levels lead to
significant drops and test scores with
language and arithmetic the average
impact equivalents having lost an entire
year of education according to a certain
study out of China now we know what has
been happening on America's college
campuses and what could be happening to
you why you feel like a dummy it's
because you haven't changed your air
filters well maybe or maybe not but you
should check it out anyway because
filter by comm is America's leading
provider of HVAC filters for homes and
small businesses choose from over 600
sizes including custom options that chip
for free within 24 hours plus they
support working Americans they
manufacture all their filters right here
in the United States save 5% when you
subscribe for auto replacement so you're
never gonna forget to change those
filters ever again it's not like you
have to think about it again once you do
it you're done filter by will save you
time and money you'll breathe better
apparently you'll become smarter in the
process so stop procrastinating that's
filter B why comm filter by com tell
them that we sent you filter by comm
again tell them that Ben sent you
because I am Ben okay so go check that
out right now as far as the as far as
president trumps you know what would it
would take to make me think the
president Trump has a movement beyond
just the 2016 election he doesn't have
to hold the house if the law says
yeah the average loss in terms of an
off-year election is usual I want to say
that it's about 27 seats 26 27 seats if
President Trump is able to hold this
below 30 seats if he's able to hold the
loss in the house below 30 seats and
Republicans are able to pick up another
three or four seats in the Senate then I
will think that there is a strong
healthy Trump movement as opposed to
just conservatives who see president
Trump is their vehicle and that'll be
encouraging in some ways for 2024 his
reelection
efforts if however from underperforms
and the Republicans lose the house in a
sweep and let's say they lose the Senate
or they barely hold
Senate by maybe one vote then you have
to start thinking that trumps base is up
right um it's not like Trump's Basin
gonna show up they are going to show up
the statistics are showing they're gonna
show up and Trump is pitching directly
to his base the the specific proposal
that was made by a lot of Trump acolytes
in 2016 is that even though Trump lost
the popular vote he created this new
coalition and the new coalition was
activated by him talking straight about
issues that he found to be key and so
when he tweeted things that most
political observers thought were crazy
that that was actually just an aspect of
his genius and him catering to this new
base that folks had misread when he said
when he makes his final closing pitch
about a migrant caravan that is
currently 600 miles from the United
States border and people say okay well
that is going to you know push him to
victory because he has a secret
connection a great understanding of the
public nobody else has we're gonna find
that out tonight we'll see that in the
vote totals hey but Trump obviously is
doubling down on exactly that strategy
he's gonna dance with the gal that brung
him and so here he was going after a
protester and listen there is a charm to
this
I'm not against President Trump being
aggressive my only question about
Trump's aggressiveness is whether there
is a way to channel it in more
productive fashion because listen I'm a
pretty aggressive dude myself
politically I'm no stranger to flipping
off protesters there but the question is
you know and I think the question has
been answered
does President Trump have any interest
in hemming himself in and using his
aggressiveness in channeled ways I think
the answer is probably no but that's
what makes him amusing to his supporters
so here's President Trump going after a
protester it is rally last night get him
out of here please get him out out
out go home to mommy
go home to mommy okay and of course this
is how the right feels about these
protesters who show up and start
screaming and president Trump didn't
stop there he also went after Elizabeth
Warren again called her Pocahontas and
then he explained he's never gonna stop
calling her Pocahontas because why would
he
the playground right
the dude knows how to play dough crab so
the question is will playing to a crowd
actually we're down to his electoral
benefit we're gonna find that out
tonight now President Trump is already
kind of preemptively reacting to the
idea that the Democrats might win the
house here was his response to the idea
that Democrats are going to investigate
every aspect of his life and hold up his
business here's what he said what he
said is he doesn't care we will have to
work a little bit differently I don't
think that's going to happen he said
that he doesn't care about their
investigations they can do whatever they
want and I can do whatever I want which
is you know we'll find out that's a lot
of confidence from the president okay so
Trump's final pitch is my base will will
take me through this my base will take
me through the Democrats final pitch is
sort of bifurcated so the Democrats have
one pitch that is directed toward their
base and then they have one pitch that's
directed at the broader American public
the pitch that is directed at their base
is we will be just as aggressive as
Trump will be just as mean as Trump will
be just as nasty as Trump and then the
and then the pitch that is directed
toward the general public is we are nice
happy wonderful people we are innocence
in American politics like newfound
babies lying in a basket at a church
door left there won't you adopt us and
make us your own right so these are the
two pitches the Democrats are making
they're making them simultaneously so on
the aggressive side we got folks like
mazie Hirono senator from Hawaii and she
is again doing this when they go low we
fight back remember Eric Holder said
when they go low we kick them here's
mazie Hirono saying the day before the
election when they go low we fight back
which obviously that but don't don't
worry Democrats have never engaged in
inflammatory rhetoric of any kind but
here's mazie Hirono doing just that
he's throwing everything out there in
trying to make sure that the midterm
elections go the way he wants by not
just dog whistles but I would call it a
bullhorn and really when they when he
goes low we have to fight back okay so
the Democrats are saying to their base
we are going to go as radical as you
think we're gonna go right that's what's
coming here we're gonna go radical Cory
Booker the ridiculous senator from New
Jersey and I say ridiculous because in
in the dictionary under the word
ridiculous is actually a picture of Cory
Booker doing his
as hands from a judicial hearing here is
cory booker on Comedy Central again
amazing it is a mate truly amazing how
all these guys get booked on late-night
television I mean III know it's
Democrats must just have superior
Booker's it can't be media buys it must
be Democrats have just great Booker's
like Cory Booker and here is Cory Booker
talking about how the criminal justice
system is a cancer on the soul of our
country yeah they're not radical at all
again and what angers me is before we
even had a Donald Trump elected we had a
cancer on our soul of our country a
criminal justice system that treats you
better if you're rich and guilty than
poor an innocent that is not true
that's not accurate I've worked in a
prosecutor's office in the prosecutor's
office we prosecuted a guy who is one of
the founders of gene therapy for sexual
Mawlid for alleged sexual molestation of
a next-door neighbor and we refuse to
prosecute a bunch of cases involving
poor innocent people because that's sort
of how our criminal justice system works
the number of actual innocent people who
are walking through the doors of a
criminal justice Center pretty low by
percentage in any case the radicalism of
the Democratic base is in the offing
it's it's obvious to anyone there's a
piece by David Graham over at the
Atlantic talking about where the
Democratic Party is moving on policy and
he says that the Democratic base has
moved pretty radically to the left is
according to Pew data 46% of Democrats
and Democratic leaning voters now
identify as liberal up from 28% ten
years ago meanwhile the percentage who
say they're moderates has dropped from
44 to 37 the number of conservatives
continues to drop too but those changes
most likely reflect the exodus of
right-leaning Democrats as both parties
become more ideologically homogeneous it
doesn't necessarily mean there's been
huge growth on the party's left wing but
when you look at these specific moves on
specific policies among the Democratic
Party faithful you see a radical shift
to the left so I think this is correct
here is the Atlantic digging into pews
data on specific positions can provide a
good sense of how Democrats are moving
leftward on certain issues especially
immigration economics and race most
astonishing is immigration as Peter
Beinart whose terrible has written
leaders in the Democratic Party have
undergone a dramatic shift for an
unalloyed support of immigration
including to a certain extent illegal
immigration in 1994 just 32 percent of
Democrats said immigrants strength in
the country now 84
% do so there's complete ideological
homogeneity inside the Democratic Party
on an issue of serious public
controversy same thing on economics 3/4
of Democrats say the government doesn't
do enough to help poor people up from
half in 1994 two-thirds say government
should regulate business more up from
half in 1994 in 1994 two-thirds of
Democrats said people could get ahead if
they were willing to work hard now only
half do alright so they're moving
dramatically and unraised it's the same
thing I'll discuss that in just one
second first let's talk about your sleep
quality so you haven't been sleeping
well I know don't like yourself you
haven't been sleeping well the reason
you haven't been sleeping well is
because you're a unique human and yet
your mattress is made for a generic
human who does not exist and who is not
you which is why you need to go over to
helix sleep helix sleep has built a
sleep quiz that takes two minutes to
complete they use the answers to match
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress whether you're a
side sleeper or a hot sleeper whether
you like a plush or a firm bed with
helix there's no more guessing in no
more confusion all you have to do is go
to helix sleep calm /ban take their two
minutes sleep quiz they will match you
to a mattress that will give you the
best sleep of your life for a couple's
helix can even split that mattress right
down the middle providing individual
support needs and feel for each side of
your marriage my wife and I have a helix
Leap mattress we did the two-minute
sleep plays it came in the mail we
unwrapped it and inflated we popped it
on bed it was good to go it's terrific
right now helix is offering up to 125
bucks off all mattress orders all these
mattresses back we have a 10 year
warranty you get to try it out for a
hundred nights risk-free so you're not
losing anything get up to 125 bucks off
at helix sleep calm slash Ben that's
helix sleep calm slash Ben for 125 bucks
off your mattress order again helix
sleep calm slash Ben go check it out so
as I say Democrats have been making a
dual pitch pitch number one is to their
base we are gonna be as radical as you
want us to be see the difference is that
Trump is only making one pitch
I'm TREB right his pitches basically
look at me this is me I don't me bask in
it right that that's Trump's pitch is
more honest than the Democrats pitch in
certain ways the Democrats pitch is to
their base we're gonna be see and then
to the rest of America we are standing
for truth and dignity we are like
insurance
salesman we're like Allstate you're in
good hands
right there's this kind of two-faced
campaign that's been going on the
Democratic Party base is obviously
resonating to the super progressive
message you can see with each one of the
candidates that they're pushing like
beta O'Rourke is being quote-unquote
mainstream as I mean he's really really
far left Andrew Gilliam is even further
left the future governor of Florida
perhaps god forbid
hey Andrew Gilliam is a radical leftist
like a Bernie Sanders radical leftist
and he's being treated as a mainstream
political figure who wants to unify
Florida even as he calls Ron DeSantis a
racist refugee from the KKK that's
because the Democratic Party base is
radical we talked about their radical
and immigration their radical and
economics and they are radical on race
too the percentage of Democrats who say
the government needs to do more to fight
racism has risen from 57 from 57% to 81%
since 2009 which is kind of amazing
because I remember when we elected a
black president twice when we were told
that that was the beginning of the
healing of America in 1994 four and ten
Democrats said that racial
discrimination was the main reason black
people couldn't get ahead in 2017 more
than six intended by the way if you
actually if you think if you changed
your mind and you think now that racial
discrimination is worse for black folks
than it was in 1994 you're crazy you're
crazy but the reality is the reason that
this has shifted is because the
demographics of the Democratic Party
have changed as the Atlantic points out
non-college educated whites have shrunk
as a portion of the base by 20% mean
blue-collar whites fled the Democrats
because of intersectionality and they
have picked up big in kind of highly
educated areas people who have gone to
four-year colleges and grad programs
because those people tend to come out on
the left and they also picked up heavily
in minority demographics so what this
Atlantic article points out is that the
Democrats are actually right of their
own base right now the Democrats believe
it or not as scary as that seems Nancy
Pelosi is actually to the right and so
is Chuck Schumer of the Democratic Party
base right now which means that the
radicalism that the Democrats are trying
to hide from the general public is very
much present with their base so as I say
there have been two messages message
number one is not radical and we will do
everything we can to change this country
and message number two is we are all
American as apple pie pushing that
message today is
Paul Krugman who's been writing the same
column or Peabody I feel like I've been
reading Paul Krugman's column over and
over and it's the same column just kind
of projected through a kaleidoscope in
any case Paul Krugman's final pitches of
course Republicans are evil and we are
awesome
any put and he suggests this literally
the title of his column last exit off
the road to autocracy they say I find it
hilarious that the media are suggesting
that Donald Trump it is alarmist on
politics it's true but you know who else
is an alarmist you're a Nobel Prize
winning columnist at the New York Times
who legitimately just suggested that
autocracy is on its way at the end of
democracy on its way we played a clip of
Bill Maher yesterday Bill Maher said the
same thing I love this there they're
very angry because in Georgia Brian Kemp
is the Republican Secretary of State and
he oversees elections and he's running
against Democrat Stacey Abrams and he
has purged a lot of names from Georgia's
voting rolls
the reason these purged those names it's
because they include people who have
shifted addresses and not actually
registered it's people who are dead it's
people who have moved out of state and
not only that they're a bunch of people
who didn't register properly and they
were purged from the voter rolls because
they didn't register properly but
according to according to Paul Krugman
this is all in attempt to get rid of the
votes now this is just another version
of the same argument the Democrats made
in 2004 with John Kerry suggesting that
the Diebold machines had been hacked and
the reason Democrats are losing is
because something nefarious is going on
with the voting population that's voter
suppression that is preventing the the
victory of Democrats it's not voter
suppression black Americans particularly
Democrats have claims are being
suppressed black voters in 2008 and 2012
voted far out of proportions their
actual proportion of the population so
that is not actually happening but Paul
Krugman suggests that we are at the end
of democracy
he says voting restrictions are almost
entirely a republican thing as always
Democrats aren't Saints but they appear
to believe in democracy while their
opponents don't really this is where
we're going Paul Krugman Republicans
don't even believe in the fundamentals
of our democracy listen if you're really
if you believe this if you're on the
left and you believe the Republicans
don't even believe in the fundamentals
of the democracy and they are out to
steal elections through rigging the
ballot box you should pick up a gun and
you should start going to war really
because that that is a coup right
that's an actual code that you're
talking about we have the balls for that
so instead you're gonna sit around and
whine about how elections don't always
go your way and then tomorrow as soon as
if Democrats do well tomorrow will be
look at this beautiful American election
system look at how wonderful our
election systems are look how honest and
god-fearing Americans are amazing how
this will shift and Paul Krugman
finishes with the crucial moment here
everyone should bear in mind what's at
stake it's not just tax cuts or health
coverage and anyone who votes based
simply on those issues is missing the
bigger story
for the survival of American democracy
is on the ballot the survival of
American democracy is on the belt listen
I didn't like this crap when I was
getting it from the right and the left
in 2016
oh my god if Trump doesn't win the
country is over oh my god
if Hillary Clinton doesn't win the
country is over no it isn't no it isn't
okay in this crap where you say stuff
like the survival of American democracy
is on the ballot really does Paul
Krugman really believe nobody's gonna
vote in 2020 is that he thinks does he
really think that the direction of the
country is that there will be no more
democracy if Republicans retain a
majority in the House and the Senate
have they ended democracy over the past
few years if not why not
apparently they're just as evil I've
been willing to cram through alleged
rapists rapists to Brett Kavanaugh
there's that evil so why didn't they
just end them out crissy then this sort
of alarmism is really really terrible i
decry it when I see it on my own side
and it's much stronger on the left than
it is on the right these days you know
you know how strong the alarmism is on
the left I'll give you some evidence so
I'm old enough to remember like because
I'm a month old I'm old enough to
remember when the Democrats thought that
Brett Kavanaugh on the on the Supreme
Court was the worst thing that had ever
happened to the United States we were
all going to die millions would perish
in hell flame and Brett Kavanaugh was a
rapist then Republicans started
investigating all of the actual
allegations over time the Senate
Judiciary Committee released more
information and it turns out there's no
information it's weird like remember
when an alleged rapist got elected
president of the United States Bill
Clinton and the Republicans never
stopped complaining about it isn't it
weird how nobody talks about Brett
Kavanaugh and it's like a month later
because it was all ginned up yeah a lot
of it was jinda by some folks on the
left now there are some people who I
think had legit
it concerns I think that was minority I
think the people in political power
we're trying to join things up for
alarmist purposes because that's what
they do okay in just a second I want to
talk a little bit more about this also
the media's role in how this election
plays out in just one second but first
let's talk about how you can cook better
tonight so you don't want to go to a
restaurant it's too expensive but not
only that it's a hassle to schlep your
kids in the car or they're just gonna
throw stuff at each other instead it is
better to stay home and cook a meal with
your family but that entails you having
me go to the grocery store and get
ingredients and buy too much and throw
out the extra or you could just
subscribe over a blue apron blue apron
delivers farm-fresh ingredients and
step-by-step recipes to your door their
mission is to make incredible home
cooking accessible to everyone they
achieve this by supporting a more
sustainable food system setting the
highest standards for ingredients
building a community of home chefs
here's how it works you let blue aprons
do the meal prep for you its dinner in
as little as 20 minutes you choose chef
designed recipes they deliver fresh
seasonally inspired ingredients you can
cook these meals in as little as twenty
minute and these are gourmet meals every
week at least three recipes are built
with your busy schedule in mind where
blue apron has done the meal prep for
you that's the sauces the spices the
ingredients the whole shebang blue apron
offers a range of recipes bursting with
flavor whether you're looking for a
quick and easy meals or full queue and
errand cooking experience blue apron
lets you choose from a range of recipe
options folks around the office have
been using blue apron for years they
just love it check out this week's menu
get your first three meals for free at
blue apron comm slash Shapiro that's
blue apron comm slash capiro to get your
first three meals for free blue apron
comm slash pair of blue apron is indeed
a better way to cook I mean I'm looking
at these meals right here and sometimes
I wish I didn't keep kosher I mean
you're looking at things like hot
italian sausage pizza with roasted
peppers and olives beef and broccoli and
cumin spiced sauce hearty vegetable
grain bowl with avocado and creamy fig
dressing I'll be honest that last one
doesn't sound as good as any of their
meat dishes but these are all awesome go
check them out right now blue apron calm
slash Shapiro okay so I do want to get
into the latest report when they
sentence you to share a committee and
also I want to get into the media bias
that's been evident throughout the
selection cycle and that continues on a
day to day basis but for an end of quote
from Barack Obama I just have to play
for you so a lot coming up but you
actually have to go over to daily where
to subscribe why should you subscribe
besides the fact that I'm asking you to
that I'm begging you to because you need
to join us tonight because starting at
5:00 p.m. Pacific we have the daily wire
backstage election special I could not
be less excited about it God King Jeremy
boring me Andrew Clavin the execrable
Michael Mills
it will all be smoking and infusing my
lungs with cigar ash which will later
cause my death from lung cancer
Alicia Krause will be here covering all
the latest election news as it happens
plus we'll even be getting Twitter
updates from our own Cassy Dillon and
Colton Haas the young gun so you won't
want to miss this as always only I want
to miss it but you won't as always only
daily where subscribers get to ask the
questions so make sure to subscribe
today if I'm going to put myself through
the hellish situation of watching this
election live on television for you but
people then you should show up okay so
show up and pay us money go check it out
ninety-nine ninety-nine a month you get
the rest of the show live and you also
get to be part of our mailbag on Fridays
you get part of the election special all
sorts of goodies when you get the annual
subscription you get this the very
greatest in all beverage vessels I have
yet to hear a complaint that I find
credible about the leftist tears hot or
cold tumblr because it is indeed that
spectacular now there have been
allegations made about this tumblr but
those allegations have been unverified
and unverifiable no location no time no
date okay so you're gonna have to go
check it out yourself left this tears
hot or cold tumblr $99 a year you get
the annual subscription or check us out
at iTunes youtube please leave us a
review on iTunes it really does help
with the rankings over there we're the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so if Democrats really believes that our
democracy was at stake they might you
know still be banging on the Brett
Kavanaugh drum remember when two weeks
ago they were saying they're gonna
impeach him remember how that went all
the way well the reason it all went away
is because on Friday the Senate
Judiciary Committee released a 400
14-page document presenting its summary
report and exhibits regarding the
allegations against Cavanaugh in the 28
page summary of its findings the
committee explained that after speaking
with 45 individuals and taking 25
written statements it did not find any
evidence to substantiate or corroborate
any of the allegations against Cavanaugh
yeah weird how that works
weird how that works but we were gonna
the Democrats were willing to destroy
that guy's life simply for political
purposes we should definitely give them
power I don't see how that goes wrong in
any in any possible way hey so as I say
Democrats have made two separate pushes
push number one to their own base where
radical we're gonna do radical stuff
push number two to the general public
we are the nicest people you will ever
meet and those cruel mean awful terrible
no good very bad Republicans we have to
act as a check on them
Stephen King in fact tweeted out
something today about this Stephen King
the the horror novelist is also a horror
on Twitter and for some reason he finds
it necessary to tweet idiotic ly about
politics on a fairly regular basis he
tweeted Donald Trump is a runaway horse
and we're all on board vote Democrat
tomorrow let's put a bit in his mouth
and rein him in first question can you
be on board a horse and I'm not I'm not
from horse country I won't say that I'm
an equestrian but I'm pretty sure you
can't be on board a horse second how do
325 million people fit on a horse third
if you think the Democrats are going to
reign Trump in and that's their only
mandate their only mandate is to
basically stop from successes that's
obviously not true their their mandate
is to push as radical policy as they
possibly can to undermine any sort of
gains that Trump has made and then to
aim for 2020 which is really what this
whole thing is about is getting rid of
Trump in the long run but the pitch that
they are making to the public and the
one that apparently is having some
effects with suburban women and this is
where you know Trump appealing to his
base plays it into the Democrat plan is
Trump doing the I'm trying look at me
you guys are not crazy
hahaha you
that NAT routine it doesn't help with
suburban women which means that the
Republicans were most likely to get
ousted this year by Republicans in
purple districts
here's Barack Obama making the final
appeal to those people and you can also
see why Barack Obama trolled the right
so Trump trolls the left Barack Obama
trolled the right that's how he got
Trump in the first place here is here's
Barack Obama but most importantly the
character of this country is on the
ballot who we are is on the ballot what
kind of what kind of politics we expect
is on the ballot how we conduct
ourselves in public life is on the
ballot how we treat other people is on
the ballot nope none of those things are
on the ballot not one of those things
are on the ballot
Obama is sitting there and telling me
about how class and decency are on the
ballot yeah this from a guy who
unleashed his vice-presidential
candidate to say that MIT Romney was
going to put black people back in Chains
yeah I know the answer is no I don't buy
that you don't buy it nobody buys it
which is how you got Trump in the first
place but that also does play into
Obama's new pitch which is I know that
you've forgotten all about me I know you
think I'm irrelevant now but weren't
things so nice and friendly back then
they weren't nice and friendly back then
but a lot of people have really short
memories I mean this is the key to
American politics everybody has a short
memory
Brett Cavanaugh's confirmation hearings
we're like a month ago and nobody even
remembers when Barack Obama was
president that was at least three
lifetimes ago and that lifetime I was a
colonel in the Prussian army I mean the
the the Barack Obama they can count on
the fact that nobody remembers that he
was a deeply divisive and polarizing
figure and so he can say stuff like this
and then point to Trump who is a deeply
divisive and polarizing figure and say
we will unify the country again and when
he says stuff like the character of the
country is on the ballot who we are is
on the ballot the implication is if you
know that you know this is what my
favorite thing when folks say on
Election Day everybody should got invoke
you know it's your civic duty to go and
vote I want everybody look at the beauty
of American democracy everybody going
and voting it's just great I want you to
go vote wait you voted for the other guy
you are the worst person I have ever
heard of I cannot believe
you voted why in the world would you
vote right when people say everyone
should vote what they mean is everyone
should vote who agrees with me and
Barack Obama is one of these right I
love that the character of the country
is on the ballot who we are is on the
ballot meaning if you vote for
Republicans then you're a bad person
what kind of politics we expect is on
the ballot how we conduct ourselves in
public life how we treat other people is
on the ballot dude you unleashed your
own IRS in the in the lead-up to a
midterm election against conservative
501 C 3s
you repeatedly lied to the American
people you suggested over and over again
the Republicans we're going to leave you
starving in the street because of their
welfare and health care policies like
it's just it's so galling to hear
politician this is why Trump was
refreshing it is also why Trump is scary
to a lot of particularly suburban female
audiences that with the gender gap in
this election is really really bad
and it's and you know I think it's going
to get worse because the Democrats again
are being then they're able to play this
two-faced game by the way because the
media are complicit so now let's get to
the media because the media's role in
this election cycle has just been
horrific it is obvious that the media
are worth from five to ten points in
every election cycle for the Democrats
they spend all day every day blasting
these Democratic messages nowhere at any
point how long did that scan the last of
Heidi Heitkamp the senator from North
Dakota who actually revealed the names
of alleged sexual assault victims in
order to push her a campaign did that
scandal last more than five seconds and
nobody's talking about it Andrew
gillum's corruption scandal has that
been on the front pages I haven't seen
it all I've heard is that he's a great
candidate they don't run and have you
meanwhile have you heard about John
James in Michigan you know the black or
the black veteran military veteran who's
running for Senate in Michigan haven't
heard a word about him nope you haven't
heard right young Kim they first should
be the first Korean congresswoman in
America and it would is there been any
talk about her at all nope not not a
word cuz she's a Republican and so let's
talk about the media and the media's
role in all of this so I do find it
absolutely hysterical that the media on
the left are so all-fired upset with
Sean Hannity for campaigning for
president Trump at least Sean's honest
enough to just get up on the stage and
do it all these other folks are not all
these other folks pretend that they are
objective or that they have our added
distance from these elect
and they don't they really are not okay
so let's take the prime example so
yesterday John James a candidate if I
mentioned is running for Senate in
Michigan he's a terrific terrific
candidate yeah you know he's running a
little bit behind I would love nothing
better than to see him join the US
Senate he'd be a terrific addition to
the body but John James was called by a
reporter and the reporter left a message
on his machine then and the reporter
forgot to hang up the phone whoops
here's what happened after the reporter
was supposed to hang up the phone and
suffice it to say reporters are not
unbiased if he'd like to call me back my
number is nine eight nine thank you yeah
if he beats her she that was shocked I
don't think it's gonna happen
EPIK and John James if he beats her man
all these reporters have a stake
okay these reporters a mistake if you
think that the folks over at CNN are not
openly rooting openly rooting for the
Democrats to take the house and to take
the Senate and to oust president from
you're out of your mind
and it would it wouldn't matter it by
the way they they were openly rooting
they've been doing this for as long as I
could remember the media coverage of
John Kerry in 2004 was just abysmal for
Republicans is the same thing in 2008
with John McCain and Barack Obama the
the media's willingness to cover for
virtually any mistake made by Democrats
and to go after virtually any sin
committed by Republicans is
extraordinary it's truly extraordinary
because in the end the media are not
offenders of the truth the media are
defenders of the media and they all want
to go home at night and they want to
sleep at night knowing that they've made
the world a better place they're
appalled as a journalist and this is
legitimately what it says that pulls a
journalist I will actually tell you in
polls a journalist I remember I was in
the ABC News studios in New York at one
point and there was a slogan on the wall
it was literally painted on the wall and
the slogan says out paraphrase said
remember the exact wording it said
something like journalists are here to
make the world a better place and I
thought to myself that is not what
journalists are here to do that is not
the role of journalists now journalists
may make the world a better place by
exposing
people to fats that they did not
otherwise have access to but the role of
the journalist is not to do that any
more than the role of the judges to do
justice Oliver Wendell Holmes justice on
the Supreme Court is very famous story
which Oliver Wendell Holmes was at a
dinner party and he's in the middle of
deciding a crucial case and he gets in
his carriage and as he gets in his
carriage the this this guy rushes up to
him and he says Justice Holmes I implore
you do justice sir and Holmes looks back
at me says that's not my job because
that's not his job his job is to
interpret the law right well if you're a
journalist it is not your job to quote
unquote make the world a better place we
have activists for that we have churches
and communities and people and lots of
other jobs for that your job is to go
out there and cover the facts that's
your job
a journalist don't see it that way and
this is how they get swelled heads
because if you actually believe that
your job was just to go out there and
cover the fact then the only egotistical
sort of self-congratulatory back-patting
that you could do would be based on
breaking a story but you certainly
wouldn't feel like better about yourself
just for sitting there and yelling at a
particular politician because that's
activism that's not actually journalism
this is why when folks look at Jim
Acosta and he pretends to be a
journalist we're like ah ha ha ha ha ha
ha here is Jim Acosta for example at a
trump rally last night Jim Acosta sees
himself as a celebrity and Jim Acosta
sees himself as I mean if you can tell
me the real difference between Jim
Acosta and Donald Trump you're gonna
have to enlighten me because this is a
very trumpian activity here's Jim Acosta
last night on CNN writing signs to mock
the crowd basically he's holding up a
sign that says
CNN is real news and then he signed it
Jim Acosta right like okay like that
this is your reporter dude your reporter
by the way I will note that there are a
bunch of Trump fans there and they're
all they're being nice to Jim Acosta
right he's never gonna talk about that
on the news he'll talk about how Trump
people were mean to him I'll never talk
about the people reaching across the the
barrier there to try and shake his head
the good news is in the end there's one
group of people we can always count on
the we can always count on two to tell
us what to do
and whose advice we can always follow
this is celebrities of course and last
night there's a telethon Judd Apatow
Pharrell bunch of anti-trump celebrities
who are telling people to vote it's a
voting telethon and um I know that it
made me want to vote it did make me want
to vote but not how they want me to vote
here's some of that epic telethon so we
are I'm in the phone banks right now um
I've been just kind of running around
saying hi everybody everyone look all
these people have you know have voters
on the line so make sure to check your
voicemails make sure your by your phones
because we have all of our celebrities
who are calling you calling you guys for
voting and getting your voting squad all
together
oh there's Tom Arnold in the background
yeah our buddy Tom Arnold anyway there's
Olivia Munn yeah this is this is the
most boring telephone I've ever seen
it's amazing all these people who are
supposedly good at TV and they can't put
together a decent telethon for voting
pretty amazing but this is that in the
end let's remember voting is voting is
great elections are great it's a tribute
to our country also we are ridiculous
people who each day stray further from
the light of God and thus we should
recall that the only way for this to
stop being the case is if we wake up to
the fact that clubbing each other over
the head with frying pans is not a
superior system to recognizing that the
government also leave us all alone so we
can go about our daily business and not
have to worry about the opinions of any
of the people I've listed on this show
okay time for some things I like and
then some things that I hate so things
that I like today sometimes somebody
puts in so much effort you just have to
pay tribute to them and this is the case
with a fellow who put together a video
on YouTube that is just it's pretty
spectacular so in x-men Days of Future
past there is a scene in which a
character a Quicksilver who's sort of
like the flash for DC but he's
in Marvel's he's SuperDuper fast where
there's a scene where he is running
around a kitchen fighting bad guys but
he's faster than all of them so he's
kind of running around and they're in
slow motion so he kind of like plants
one of their fists against their own
face they punched himself in the face he
has one of them shoot the other one and
he throws a frying pan so that when time
speeds up again then the frying pan will
clock the guy in the head somebody took
that scene and cut a a fully computer
animated version of that scene except
with me as Quicksilver being protested
by a bunch of auntie fatigues and it's
pretty it's pretty well done and it's
pretty funny so here's a little bit of
that
[Music]
I'd like to do
is to save every day to eternity
just a spell that I am waiting what this
year's a guy holding a marks book I
write my that nude there are a couple of
women in and made scale outfits who are
pulling airports and then there's a guy
holding up sensation girls dashes to
sign stamina but I wet my bed in Poland
branch sheets
pretty spectacular okay well you can go
watch the whole thing on YouTube well
we'll also try to post a link on I think
I tweeted it out yesterday it's really
funny so go check it out obviously this
is not an endorsement of violence it is
an endorsement of placing me in famous
movie scenes because that stuff's funny
man okay other things that I like so I
do have to admit that Michael Moore
selection analysis is kind of hilarious
and wonderful
so Michael Moore is Michael Moore and
requires no further exploitation he was
on MSNBC with Chris Hayes discussing
this election and he said like I think
Democrats are gonna win but Democrats
have a way of losing elections they
should win and let me just say if in
fact Democrats do not take the house
tonight I will never sit I will never
stop tuning in to MSNBC I just won't it
will just stay on a loop so here's
Michael Moore with Chris Hayes yes this
all could portend well but but the
Democrats are professionals at losing
elections that they win or should have
won and we are up against Republican
Party okay
he is right now this is where I caution
Republicans and I say that again a data
point is not a pattern so we'll have to
see what the election results are like
tonight before we say that there is a
robust Trump movement that can outlast
all the polls that polls don't mean
anything the final note on that Chris
Hayes Michael more segments we have that
split-screen again I just want to make a
quick note here that you know there are
a lot of memes going around on Twitter
me before the 2016 election meet after
the 2016 election this is Chris Hayes
before the 2016 election Chris Hayes
after the 2016 election okay time for a
couple of quick things that I hate so
folks talked about this yesterday but I
was remiss because I thought there are
more important things to talk about
still it does belong in things that I
hate so Pete Davidson is an alleged
comedian for a Saturday Night Live who
apparently is also a big fan of orange
is the new black and stole Hillary
Clinton's pantsuit I don't know why
exactly he's wearing a shirt that makes
him look like he's picking up roadside
trash on a furlough from the prison but
in any case he was going after Dan
Crenshaw who's a congressional candidate
dan Crenshaw also happens to be a
military veteran who lost
I to an ie D in Afghanistan and then
proceeded to go back for further tours
here is Pete Davidson an idiot best
known for dating ariana grande and now
he's will no longer be famous because
he's no longer dating ariana grande
which means that his star has risen and
fallen rather quickly also just you know
as long as we're going after people's
physical appearances which is fair
because he goes that you're gonna hear
him go after Dan Crenshaw's physical
appearance Pete Davidson looks like he
sucks the lifeblood from small children
as they sleep I mean that's a he looks
like a refugee from from a vampire movie
there's and I'm sorry to break it to him
but I mean as long as we do mock
people's looks let's just go all in on
this thing so the plot in which Pete
Davidson is a star apparently is that he
was a vampire who was arrested for the
murder of a of a young virgin after
killing her and draining her of her
blood they arrested him and they put him
in jail and then they had him clean
roadside trash but he escaped to do bad
comedy on SNL that's the back story of
this clip here's Pete Davidson this
guy's kind of cool a Dan Crenshaw you
may be surprised to hear he's a
congressional candidate from Texas and
not a hit man in a porno movie
I'm sorry I know he lost his I am in war
whatever he lost is why in war or
whatever right yeah but like not or
whatever in war to defend your stupidity
so that you could date ariana grande and
then break up with her cuz you're a
loser so there so there's that Dan
Crenshaw by the way his response is all
class here was Dan Crenshaw's response
this dude's an actual American hero as
opposed to an undead vampire who has to
hide from the Sun because his skin
sparkles here's Dan Crenshaw well you
know we don't need to be we don't need
to be outwardly outraged I don't need to
demand apologies from them they can do
whatever they want but I would like him
and Saturday Night Live to recognize
something which is that veterans across
the country probably don't feel as
though their wounds they received in
battle should be the subject of a bad
punchline for a bad joke anew and here's
the real atrocity than all this it
wasn't even funny
right it was not original it was not
funny it was just mean-spirited and
that's that that's how I feel about it
okay so you know good for Dan Crenshaw
yeah I I agree and I'm not in the call
on Pete Davidson to make an apology
business I don't really care about this
stuff like I'm not gonna pretend that
I'm deeply disturbed I do think it's
indicative of a mind set up a bunch of
people who have never met a military
member and it's obvious they've never
met him elbows I remember really I mean
there is one of the the saddest things
about American life right now is that a
very small percentage of folks in the
United States had served in the military
which means a fairly small percentage of
people particularly on the coasts have
ever met somebody who serves in the
military or our friends with somebody
who serves in the military and that
leads to making jokes like that
obviously and that's not mentioned none
of this is meant to excuse anybody on
any side of the aisle who does this I
mean I ripped Trump when he went after
McCain for his military service so I
just find this sort of stuff really
off-putting although I will say that at
a baseline I think Trump has more
respect for the military than somebody
like Pete Davidson probably does so we
will leave it at that
we'll leave Pete Davidson to his to his
you know presumably after this he'll
turn into a bat and you know go sleep
upside down in a cave or something or go
back into the coffin attitude for the
evening so it's a recover from his long
day in any case tonight we will be here
with our election special I expect
to be here to because misery loves
company if I have to suffer here with
Michael Knowles and Andrew Clavin and
Jeremy Boren and have to be here for
1,000 hours watching election returns
coming in and not be at home with my
wife and children because it's like
crossing Antarctica alone if I have to
be here you should be here too and you
should you should definitely become a
member so that you can be part of the
so-called party either or be square I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing